so we touched on some excellent points
the right way to start screenwriting
let's talk about the wrong way to start
oh that's the question yeah that's a
question
sorry i think that's offshore no it's
okay it's okay i think the wrong way to
start is just assuming you know how this
thing works right assuming that you know
what screenwriting is and so you don't
have to do any research that you don't
have to um try to hone your craft in any
way that you don't have to read any
screenplays that you can just wake up
and write right and even though i said
earlier
writing is a part of it right that's the
first thing you want to do you want to
start getting your ideas out to see what
they are right but then to assume that
that's all it takes is the wrong place
to start
it's also the wrong place to start to
assume that you don't have to know
anything about the business right as
writers you're your own advocate you are
your business and you're walking into a
business so as much as it's creative
there's also the business part of it and
so you can have the best screenplays out
there but if you don't know how to play
this game of getting into the business
then you're not going to be in the right
mindset of it um
and also assuming that you're just going
to be able to jump right in right like
there is like there's no uh
putting in the midnight oil you know
what i mean of realizing that this is
long game
this hollywood thing is long game so
going back to that networking across
thing right
five years from now 10 years from now
all of those people are going to be in
different places not two days from now
so the same thing is true with your
writing it's a process so going back to
knowing the business realizing that i
can write a screenplay today and it
might not get made until seven years
from now
right so realizing that it's not a quick
thing it's not an in and out
you know kind of machine which is why
you have to ask yourself what is it that
i want from this what is my end goal am
i trying to be a professional writer am
i just trying to get this one thing done
and if that if it's only that one thing
do i really want to put the time and
energy into doing it
another place uh that you shouldn't
start from is thinking that the writer
has total creative control
right this is a collaborative effort
filmmaking is so realizing that there
will always be someone critiquing your
work always always always always and
then learning how to separate yourself
from that so you aren't taking taking it
personally a no to your work is not a no
to you as a person like take that in
you know breathe it
understand it that no to your work may
mean this is not the right work for our
company it may mean this is not what
we're looking for right now it may mean
there's growth necessary on your part
that's good information to hear you want
to hear great i need to grow because now
you know what to you know what to work
towards versus not hearing anything at
all because that happens in hollywood
too where people just don't respond to
you at all you don't get anything right
but getting that no tells you
i now am open to try to sell this
somewhere else this wasn't the right fit
for it and getting that information so i
know a lot of people uh say you need
tough skin when you come into this um
this industry and yes that may be true
but if you can learn how to disconnect
from your work equaling your worth
right
then the tough scan is not necessary as
much because you know that they're not
critiquing you
right they're talking about what's on
the page and when someone else develops
it or someone else purchases it they're
now trying to get it to fit the mold of
their brand which is why you have to do
your research at the first place to ask
yourself is this the best place for my
baby is this the best place for my story
right
if you decide to pitch something to nbc
it's got to feel like nbc
so that means the executives are going
to mold it into
nbc that means they might lose trim some
of the stuff that you think is very
important it may mean that they're going
to add some stuff that you never thought
about that's going to make this the best
show to ever hit television so you have
to be open to that collaborative process
so i think those three or four things
are really important that if you're not
understanding that you're starting off
in the wrong place
can you have
thick skin
tough skin
and not be callous
yes i think so
i think that thick skin that people are
talking about is being able to receive
feedback not take it personally and then
therefore not react from an emotional
place and start to burn bridges
with that being said there are plenty of
callous people in the industry
a lot of the people who tell people they
need to have tough skin don't have tough
skin themselves
right
everyone is sensitive you know and in
the world that we live in right now
everyone is sensitive and then you come
into an industry where um
we are creating things and like erica
badu said people are sensitive about
their stuff right so
i think that thick skin just really
comes from a place of understanding that
this is not about you and it's about the
work and the stuff but you are going to
deal with all kinds of different
personalities just like you would in any
kind of industry
there are people who are not so nice
here right there are people who are rude
here and then there are people who
aren't and there are people who want to
help you and they're people who want you
to grow but at the end of the day you're
still going to hear no more than more
than you hear yes right someone does
have to approve and accept and affirm
the thing that you're giving to them and
oftentimes you're not going to hear the
thing you wanted to hear and if you
don't know how to disconnect if you
don't know how to grow that tough skin
that they say then it can start to chip
away at who you are right um and that
should not be um the end goal so yeah i
think you can definitely have tough skin
and not end up being a callous person
but it takes work
you know it takes work
and then you also said not knowing the
industry so if i want to jump in one of
the wrong ways is to not do research on
the industry and who i'm pitching and
different things like that what if i say
you know what i'm just really good at
winging it i've always been good at
sports i can fit into any room i'm a
chameleon in some ways i don't really
need i can just just get me there and
and i'll i'll know who's in charge yeah
i have a radar for that do it
try it out because at the end of the day
no one has the same true hollywood story
right everyone gets into this industry
in a different way
so if that's your strong suit
getting into the room and selling
yourself the hard part is getting into
the room
right when you get in there let your
personality shine you know do the thing
that works for you because nine times
out of ten if that works for you in
other places it'll work for you here as
long as whatever it is you're saying can
actually be backed up by what's on the
page a lot of people think what's on the
page is fantastic and wonderful and it
just isn't right so now you went into
the room and you oversold
right you went into the room and you
said i have this thing and then we read
this thing and it's like
no you don't right so making sure that
you're not going to oversell because now
people are going to remember that you
may not be able to get into the room the
next time but other than that if you're
a winged kind of person wing it the
question is how do you get in the room
in the first place in order to wing it
that's why you have to know about the
industry
do you ever see that where someone who's
kind of underconfident they actually
have really excellent work yeah and it's
the ones that are like beating the the
chest and wait you just gotta see and
it's like might not be there yet almost
always
it's almost always that and i say almost
because there are outliers but it's
almost always that usually the people
you know the more introverted more i'm
not really sure you know what's
happening here you read their stuff and
it's like you got something here you can
be confident about that and then it's
the people who say i know i have this
thing you read it and it's like you
don't know how to format a scene heading
so no you don't have this thing you know
quite yet so yes it happens all the time
and this is not necessarily an industry
that expects people to be humble you
know what i mean so i don't i don't
my i don't mock them for being
overconfident
however
that thing on the page is what
represents you period it doesn't matter
what's coming out of your mouth you know
what i mean so you have to be able to
back it up which is why i said earlier
you need that other set of eyes you need
someone you can trust on your team as a
script consultant that's what i become i
become a part of your team everybody
needs a script consultant even if they
don't know that we exist right but once
you find someone you need someone who
can objectively look at your stuff and
let you know if you're doing the thing
you intend to do
good or bad right and if we don't have
those checks and balances then all we
have is our own confidence all we have
is our own ego and you can sometimes
oversell um what you have going on but i
don't think your overconfidence is bad
you know what i mean you know i would
rather that than you falling apart
because you get a no you know what i
mean but really trying to make sure that
whatever it is you're selling can be
seen on the page is the most important
thing there are plenty of people walking
around hollywood with egos we have a lot
of those so i'm not going to say you
can't have an ego sure you can you know
what i mean but you got to be able to
back it up
well what if i say though you know i ran
this by my brother-in-law and he owns
his own company and this guy he knows
his stuff so
it's already good i already know that
yeah does he know screenwriting
no but he's built a business and he's
very successful look at the end of the
day i'm always going to say try it
try it go with it send your screenplay
to one of these script coverage
companies send your screenplay to me
send it to a competition send it to a
film festival and see what happens right
because maybe you're right i'm not going
to say that you don't have natural
talent i have natural talent right i've
sent screenplays out that haven't been
looked at you know by other people and
they've done decently well so i can't
say that that won't happen for another
person but at the end of the day you
want someone who understands not only
the industry but also understands uh
writing you know understands the medium
of screenplays so that they can give you
actual criticism and critique if not
then it's just opinion right like you
can have your mom or your dad or your
brother read as much as you want they'll
like it or don't won't like it but can
they tell you why
can they tell you how to fix things or
are they just giving more opinion and
everybody out there has got an opinion
it doesn't mean that it's going to make
your story better so if you feel that
you don't need another set of eyes
totally fine put it out in the into the
universe and see if you get what you
need in return and if you don't then
you'll have to change your tactic just
like your characters have to do you know
when they aren't getting the things that
they need
you